[Musique]
je suis candidate à la présidence de la
république
c'est une candidature de plus à gauche
et je pense qu'on en n'avait pas
spécialement besoin c'est une
candidature de plus donc c'est une
mauvaise nouvelle pour celles et ceux
qui cherchent l'union de la gauche qui
cherche à rassembler estimait qu'il
fallait faciliter la victoire de la
gauche parce qu'elle est essentielle et
l'aîné c'est arrivé si tard avec une
proposition qui ajoute une candidature
je crois que pas grand monde ne comprend
aujourd'hui qu'il s'agit pas de faire
des petites touches et puis de faire de
la com c'est pas ça la politique
regardez l'état du pays faut être un peu
sérieux quand on se présente à une
élection présidentielle faut avoir des
réponses concrètes crédible pour
gouverner pas simplement un moment donné
pour faire des réseaux mais ce n'est pas
le cas des faire des images après le
meeting en réalité augmentée voici le
mythique hymne merci et olfactives et en
même temps avec une expérience de vision
à 360° ce que vos téléphones portables
j'ai fait partie de celles qui ont le
plus prôné l'union simplement je vais
vous donner un scoop c'est que ça se
fera pas voilà ça ne se fera pas parce
que il ya plusieurs candidats à gauche
qui n'en veulent pas et s'en va là les
citoyens s'exprimant à travers cette
consultation mais qu'il n'y aura aucune
conséquence sur vous puisque de toute
façon que ce soit mélenchon jadot ou
moins et bien nous continuerons et je le
redis projet contre projet il ya une
gauche
qui aujourd'hui réd ses comptes sur le
quinquennat hollande ça fait d'élever le
direct et et montebourg et m'ont dit
c'est le spectre du quinquennat hollande
nous ne sommes pas concernés par les
mésaventures du centre gauche et nous
n'irons pas nous disputer avec eux parce
que nous ne sommes pas concernés par la
peau pétition entre le parti radical de
gauche le madame taubira et le parti
socialiste de madame hidalgo moi je
serai parents d'un enfant handicapé je
serait effondré pour voir la phrase même
si depuis les appauvrit les revenus de
votre dette le candidat à la
présidentielle a évoqué la scolarisation
des enfants handicapés
il dénonce l'obsession inclusive une
mauvaise manière faite aux enfants ils
préconisent de ne pas les intégrer dans
les écoles classiques si vous
journalistes vous pourriez comprendre
que si parfois les gens sont excédés par
vous c'est parce qu'ils en ont assez que
vous prêtiez toujours sur les petites
affaires au lieu de vous occuper dès
lors en fait c'est mon ami je crois pas
que ce soit un monstre qui déteste les
enfants handicapés il faut tu sais pas
dire de bêtises mais il est mal à la
barre dont la phrase c'est pas de la
maladresse c'est très clair ce qu'il dit
ce qu'il dit c'est très clair il faut
l'écouter les reliques ou des golfs je
suis le candidat du réel et moi je parle
du réel les autres parlent de
l'idéologie pas il soit qu'il s'agit là
une ligne sur cette question là qui sont
la faim notamment à côté de la plaque si
vous voulez il répète des éléments de
langage j'ai trouvé extrêmement choquant
la brutalité des propos d'eric zemmour
ce je crois que c'est une vraie
méconnaissance du combat que mènent les
familles d'enfants en situation de
handicap et rsa monsieur mélenchon tous
la brutalité d'eric zemmour oui la
brutalité du réel parce que le réel et
brutale parce que les souffrances de ces
enfants sont très brutal je suis écoeuré
par ce genre de remarque pense que cet
homme nam ne sera même pas compte du mal
qui fait quand il parle comme ça en
californie aux fidji au pérou ou en
nouvelle zélande le niveau de l'eau est
monté ces dernières heures
conséquence de la spectaculaire éruption
volcanique sous marine au large des îles
tonga novak djokovic ne défendra pas son
titre au tournoi de melbourne
la justice australienne a confirmé
l'annulation de son visa au motif que le
joueur n'est pas vacciné et qu'il
présente un risque pour l'ordre public
du pays